Almost everybody has had acne.
Acne, also known as pimples or zits, is a normal part of growing up.
When kids reach puberty, their bodies experience many changes.
As the levels of hormones in teenager's bodies change,...
...teenagers frequently develop pimples.
Additionally, many people continue to have pimples after puberty.
What can a teenager or an adult do to cure pimples?
Unfortunately, many cures people think will work on pimples are really just myths.
Many people believe that popping pimples is the best way to get rid of them.
Popping a pimple will actually push the germs further under the skin,...
...which can cause more redness and pain, or even turn into an infection.
For that reason, doctors who specialize in skin problems...
...normally encourage people not to pop their pimples.
Also, do you think that washing your face frequently will help get rid of pimples?
Of course, washing your face is a good idea,...
...but washing your face too much could irritate the skin more, making the pimples even worse.
Another widely believed myth is that not wearing makeup can help reduce a person's chance of developing pimples.
In fact, some kinds of makeup or face creams...
...actually have special medicine in them to fight pimples.
As a result, not all of them are bad for you.
Along with makeup, people claim that eating fatty foods or chocolate can cause acne.
The truth is that eating a candy bar or a piece of pizza will not cause pimples.
Even so, both teenagers and adults should still try to eat foods...
...that are good for their bodies and their skin.
Another myth is that stress can cause acne.
Stress comes in many forms, like a big exam at school or problems with friends.
While it is true that stress can cause a person's skin to create extra oil,...
...this extra oil does not necessarily cause more pimples.